[Music]
this week the european union removed the
united states from its safe travel list
recommending that so-called
non-essential american visitors tourists
basically be vaccinated tested or
quarantined well in this morning's new
york times our dr david agus along with
former british prime minister tony blair
and oxford university vaccine expert sir
john bell lay out the case
for a quote global data-driven system on
vaccines to make international travel
easier dr agus a cbs news medical
contributor joins us now from l.a dr
aegis good morning so this is a global
system to basically open up borders with
mutual recognition of vaccines do i have
it right
yeah i mean so we certainly need to do
that but it needs to go a step further
and that not every vaccine works against
every variant and the data change all
the time you may have a vaccine that
works now but without a booster you're
not protected against getting a variant
and potentially spreading a variant so
the qr code obviously is critical as we
see on the screen now but the problem is
is that we need to start to look at the
data in the real world with every
vaccine there are vaccines that are not
approved in the united states that are
being used across the globe and so we
need to look at them and say hey this
vaccine is okay to come to the united
states you know the state of the art now
is this i mean this is my vaccine card
this is not high tech yeah but you know
the the data will give us information
about vaccine effectiveness but
comfort level in different countries of
who they want to let in and what feels
safe to them politically and otherwise
it's going to vary so how do you get
countries on the same page with this
sort of uniform system
great question tony is that we need to
rise above nationalism here and so
there's a meeting of the g20 the the
largest economies of the world this
weekend the health ministers and what
we're proposing is that it it is a
national international standard so every
country agrees which are the vaccines
that are working at the present time and
if you have these vaccines you can go
into countries with x sort of
restrictions right now it's changing all
the time it's confusing and it's very
political i don't want a vaccine from
russia i don't want a vaccine from china
they need to be data-driven
you know david a lot of us feel that the
vaccine is our superpower but now that
you can still get covet even when you
have the vaccine what insurance do you
have that even if you've gotten a
vaccine it's safe for you to travel
you know right now you're right is that
there are breakthrough cases those
breakthrough cases i think are still
evident the vaccines work because you're
not being hospitalized and getting
seriously ill but you certainly need
testing together with vaccines in many
places with delta variant ongoing and
we're going to get ups and downs over
the next year or so as new variants come
and with each of these we have to look
at every vaccine and saying can the
person with that vaccine get the virus
and transmit the virus or can't they and
the rules have to follow appropriately
yeah and by the way this comes back to
jobs jobs jobs about 1 in 10 jobs
globally are tied to tourism
international travel the movement of
people and goods dr david agus with a
possible solution thank you very much